you
[Music]
I'm here to talk about testing in prod
and when that can be really awesome idea
for your business I'm Dan MC - at heap a
tiny bit about my background I joined us
our first hire in July 2013 my first
project was building the initial version
of the data system that powers this
product like how all the data actually
gets into it how I make it a useful and
scaleable and all that stuff before that
I was an engineer - company called
Palantir if any of you heard of that
before that I studied math and CS at
Stanford I did a bunch of deep learning
research that's kind of my thing then if
you want to geek out about that after
come talk to me this is me and my happy
place this is me in a different happy
place I guess so
what curve day I'll give you a brief
primer on what Heep is just the minimum
stuff that you like to make the rest of
the conversation makes sense then I'll
talk about testing and prod and how we
do that and why that works so well for
us and then situations and work that in
which that can work well for you and
I'll give you some thoughts on how to
generalize this approach and some pro
tips if you want to pursue it yourself
and finally I'll walk through an example
of a totally different scenario that we
found in which you can apply the same
basic idea and it turns out to work
quite well so what is heap heap solves
the problem of creating data sets about
your customers and making them useful
so heap is a tool that you would use to
capture everything that your users do on
your website or in your app and make
that useful answer questions later find
insights do analytics power your
business workflows whatever I think it's
easier to understand what this is in
contrast to traditional tools and
traditional tool let's say I have this
website and it has a page on it and it
has a video on that page and I want to
know how many people click to that play
button on that page so I can know if
it's going up or down or and answer some
kind of business question this is this
is how you answer that question in every
other tool you're probably like vaguely
familiar with this at least in concept
you add an event every single tool works
the same way except for heap you there's
a tracking API where you add an event
listener to that button and then you
write this one line of tracking code and
you fact that the user watch that video
or something and then you ship this code
and you get the data
answer your question so this turns out
to be very limiting because your ability
to iterate on your data set is really
poor like every time you want to add
something to your data set like a new
event or track a new thing
or fix a problem with it or anything
like that you have to go get an engineer
to change your tracking code and wait
for the co to ship and wait for your
users to upgrade and data has to
accumulate on it's like multi-week multi
month cycle data rate and what we found
is that the most interesting stuff is
usually twelve iteration steps deep when
you're asking questions that you didn't
even know to ask up front so the
iteration speed is key and this workflow
is really painful so the heap approach
to this problem is to capture everything
you users do up front and then let you
analyze it later so your your use of
heap starts with installing and snippet
like this or there's an SDK in
ios/android react native that you
install in your product and we will
start capturing every click every page
every form submission whatever and in
your tool and then when you have a
question you can answer it so the way
you answer it is you do what's called
defining an event so instead of tracking
something you you create a virtual event
recreated definitions all terms that
mean the same basic thing so this is an
overlay of your website in heap with
where you can you can't I don't know how
well you can see but you like if you
mouse over that play button you get a
little thing on the right that tells you
exactly what it thinks a play is and you
can you know it'll pick out the
distinctive CSS elements of that thing
or some other key property that makes it
the the click play then you can give it
a name where that shiny red arrow is and
you can click that define button and
then you have this watch uplands video
event and you can use it like an event
in any other analytics tool you can make
graphs or do conversion funnels or
cohort analysis behavioral analysis all
those sort of things you want to do and
then one thing that is not obvious from
this this screenshot demo is I define
this event today but we have data going
back retroactively lis two months before
so that's part of the power of this
product is that you can add something
and then have data going back years
instantaneous leading answer question so
this is a this is powerful but it's a
hard product to build and start for a
lot of reasons like the for example the
that snippet is very complex the actual
problem of capturing everything users do
in an app or in an or in a website is
really complex and there's a million
edge cases and details and product
product details you need to get right to
get that right and there's a whole bunch
of other design questions that come from
this this stuff we're mostly gonna talk
about today is the data engineering
problem of heap and and how that is hard
and some things we've done to make that
work well for us so some core challenges
to the data engineering challenge of
heap the first is that
just more data we're capturing like 10x
or 100x as much stuff that users do
because we're capturing everything they
do as opposed to just the stuff you
flight listed so the data set itself is
just much larger and we won't ever care
about 95% of the things that are in it
because they won't ever match any those
definitions most of the random clicks
your users do or just noise so the data
set is much larger and has much worse
signal-to-noise so the data engineering
prom is harder from that and then
another one that we'll talk a lot about
a lot today is that the the variability
in ways users use this product is
enormous and that makes any sort of
system harder to build like the
different kinds of analyses that people
use this for and the different shapes of
their data set by different customer all
of that variability is different ways
your product could perform poorly like
any any higher variability problem is a
harder engineering problem so we'll talk
to fair bit about that today but that's
that's a difficult part about this every
every analysis users do is unique and ad
hoc and sort of like boundless in
different ways it can differ and finally
the this is maybe a little bit subtle
but it's it's super important to us is
that it the the data set that you're
using in heap has this fundamental
indirection in it we're capturing raw
stuff like clicks and pages and form
submissions but you're analyzing
semantically meaningful events like
watches of a video or something like
that and the mapping between those two
is dynamic and that's the power of this
product is you can add a new thing there
or change the definition any given point
in time but that makes it harder to
build this system in a performant way as
an example of the kind of thing that you
can't do that you would otherwise do any
sort of system like this a bog-standard
technique would be you want to partition
your data by the type of the event so
you might want to have your checkouts in
one section of disk segregated from your
your signups or your orders and several
tons of discs so when you want to do an
analysis of check outs you can just read
a tightly bounded part of disk and this
is faster because it's all in one place
and you're not reading any stuff it's
extraneous and it's also a contiguous
scan which gives you better locality
it's faster than doing a bunch of point
reads this is like a totally standard
technique you can't really do this in a
heap or you can't use certainly much
harder to do because what is and isn't a
check out can change in a given point in
time you can update that definition your
analyses have to update retro actively
or you can like add a new thing and
you'd have to reorganize the whole disk
accordingly so like this is just an
example the point of this isn't we can't
do partitioning it's a bummer the point
of this is like a lot of techniques
don't work so it's a hard date
engineering problem like the basic if
you were to boil down like data system
performance engineering to like one
incredibly reductive idea it might be
something like organize your data so as
to make your workload performant and
fundamentally we can't do that as well
because the workload is in terms of
these in terms of this like layer of
quicksand that we can't control so it's
a it's a hard data engineering problem
so how do you make this thing fast and
just to be clear when I talk about
making this thing fast what I would I
like this isn't a vanity thing like
users hate looking at a thing that has a
30 second spinning thing but like maybe
they'll deal if it means they can get
data they wouldn't get elsewhere the
reason this is a really killer problem
for our business is that it determines
who can and can't use the product like
if we make this product 2x faster that
means that customers who are 2x larger
can use the thing at the same
performance so that's the real thing for
businesses that the like the addressable
market is bounded by how fast we can
make the analyses here so it's a
superkey problem for us and we talk
about making this faster there's a
couple like ground rules that I'll try
to establish are like goals for the
process of making this faster when
you're starting out you can just do like
DBA whack-a-mole stuff where you've read
your slow query log you find a slow
query you add an index or something make
it fast like repeat that until you've
like covered mostly known problems
that'll work fine at some point you'll
exhaust all the easy stuff the
low-hanging fruit or your usage will be
large like we have hundreds of thousands
of queries per week and thousands of
them are things we want to make faster
so like that kind of thing isn't gonna
work you need to be able to make large
systemic big chunk improvements like
overall the p95 moved to this percentage
per quarter not able to do that
whack-a-mole style anymore
another goal for us is that we want to
be able do this in a predictable way you
want to be able to get like a turning
the crank performance improvement
reliably every month every quarter or
something like that I think quite often
performance engineering is treated like
this like big adventure of discovery and
like will deliver a 10x win when we get
it or like it's a big fishing expedition
or something like that
we wanted this to be a predictable
reliable thing that we could do with
people who weren't like you know God's
gift to Linux tuning or something like
that with like regular yet engineers
could reliably produce wins here and
finally this is the data layer of a data
product so our tolerance for for bugs is
really low like our tolerance for any
kind of data loss or serious
formance regressions or any sort of
incorrectness and results like it's a
super risky area of the stack where we
have basically no tolerance for problems
so another way to think about this is we
want to build a factory for making
performance improvements and this is
basically the system of coming for doing
this
here's a quick case study and like what
what used to happen or like what has
happened before we wanted to roll at ZFS
ZFS is a shiny new file system new for
file system means like it's 15 years old
we wanted ZFS because it has file system
of a compression and our dataset is huge
and super compressible and if the file
system Chris presses it for you you can
have like half the disk or even less
than that and that's a huge cost savings
we could pass on to our customers or
keep ourselves and it's no code changed
to our product because it's in the file
system so it's a super attractive thing
for us but there's also something we
knew was risky so we did a bunch of
research and we built a custom
benchmarking suite for this and we
evaluated our product extensively on all
the angles that we knew that it that it
was risky like we write profiled it we
got what we thought was a representative
set of analysis queries and we tested
those and we tested some maintenance
operations and database back engine blah
blah but we tested all the things we
could think of up front to test
everything was Green we were super
excited we decided to roll the thing out
it this is a picture I took of what
happened next is like a huge train wreck
of a thing I think like is it is an
enormous stubbed toe for the business we
we started rolling it out it took more
than a month to roll the thing out
because we're have like a petabyte scale
dataset this isn't something we can just
do overnight it's really takes a long
time duties and everything was fine for
weeks and then weeks into the rollout we
started to see serious problems which is
a bad time to see those because you're
already weeks into the thing and you
can't just turn it off and the basic
problem we had was that we couldn't
ingest the incoming data fast enough
which is a pretty fundamental problem it
means like data is queuing up not
getting into our system we're accruing
latency so like we had an analysis we
were able to coordinate to a small
number of customers but for those
customers they were looking at I think
it was like hey we don't have an out
data from a product for the last month
sorry which is it completely broken like
we just had to refund them it's
completely broken unusable experience so
we couldn't adjust data fast enough this
broken product and and resolving this
took weeks it's like the worst case
where you have you're like weeks in and
like kana in too deep to go back we're
going back gonna take weeks and it's
like fixing a plane in flight that's
already on fire it's like not a good
time there's a bad part of my life so
super bad but kind of tellingly this
wasn't some Yolo like expedition that we
did this was something that we really
thoroughly vetted we had one of our best
engineers safe like safety evaluate this
for like a month beforehand we did a
bunch of research this is the most
thoroughly at the time that we had ever
vetted a change for analysis layer and
it was an enormous like problem mistake
self-inflicted problem for the business
so we tried really hard to vet this
thing didn't work at all and if you're
curious about like specifically what
didn't went wrong the benchmarking had
some holes that in retrospect now that
we knew how it didn't work we're kind of
easy to see but at the time I think
we're pretty non-obvious one in
particular was it we were testing with
disks that were less full than in prod
and ZFS has nonlinearities around write
performance given the fullness of disk
another one was that the benchmark was a
scaled-down version of a data set on a
scaled-down machine
but scaling up that is at hand the
machine it was like a non linear either
didn't actually doesn't work the way you
would think it would
those are both like reasonable things to
do in a in a benchmark I think kind of
the point of this is that like if you
try to foresee any possible way that
your thing could have a problem I think
that's kind of like an endless fool's
errand of a thing and this also wasn't
the first time we had had something
where the benchmarking didn't agree with
prod we'd had other changes where the
benchmarking results were that something
was gonna be a spectacular win and then
we were allowed to prod and there's like
no appreciable change there's kind of a
dud or something like that so we need a
new system to do this I think the moral
of the story is that anyway your testing
is different from prod is surface area
for surprises when you get to prod like
totally ideal world you would fork the
universe and play forward your change in
the status quo ten years and see which
one has the better business value or
something like that
obviously you can't do that but you're
gonna do some degree aggradation of that
and any degradation of that is surface
area for problem so so we thought
instead of starting from a benchmark and
trying to bake in all of the possible
ways that we can ever imagine this
becoming a problem in prod what if we
just found that invented a safe way
to get this thing into prod so we could
expose ourselves at variance and at that
entropy of prod sooner
thus shadow prot which is kind of the
the system that we cooked up it's
actually really simple our software's
built around a query cluster that has a
master and some number of workers and
workers do all the work of evaluating
queries we build a system that basically
picks one of those workers and
replicates the data set of it completely
to another machine and replicates all
incoming reads and writes that machine
to the second one and allows us to
measure exactly the performance that we
would have gotten from from the system
you can think of it like an a/b test for
your database performance so this thing
is in prod in every meaningful sense we
just ignore the results from it but in
every other sense this thing is baking
in prod here's the picture version same
basic concepts so we have we have a
cluster there's data coming in from
Kafka and it gets fed to all these
different worker nodes which are then in
queried from a master node via the app
and all we're doing is adding a
additional node to this that's a clone
of one of the nodes that gets a
replicated set of queries on the read
path and it gets all the incoming data
on the right path and we've written a
little shim layer in our app where you
can run you'll run both variants so the
things such that it hits both the
different workers is actually I hope
this isn't super complicate I think the
fact that simple as part of what makes
it a good idea so the process for
evaluating it changes you you spin up a
machine that has that's the same as a
prod machine except it has your variant
in it like in in the prior case it would
have been that the dotted line machine
ax has has ZFS running on it instead of
XFS which is fessing had before and
otherwise they're the same and then you
can evaluate exactly the problems you'd
have had and we would have noticed that
we couldn't ingest incoming data fast
enough before it was in prod we were
able to you know fix the thing so we've
been doing this for bout 18 months and
we're at the point where evaluating a
change to our data layer takes about two
to four weeks of wall time most of which
is passive most of that time is
hydrating the new machine or waiting for
stuff to happen so that we can
accumulate a dataset of performance and
then compare it like you want to capture
at least a full week of data for us
because there's intro week variation and
how people use a product all that stuff
but like it's like two to four weeks of
time maybe like one to three weeks at
most of engineering time depending on
the complexity of the change and we've
been able to improve the performance
product by like twenty to forty percent
per quarter reliably and that
that compounds that's awesome that's
like over the last 18 months you can
prove this thing by about 11x which is a
lot for especially because we there's no
like large rewrite that we ever did it
was just like clockwork every quarter it
gets 30% faster and then over that
compounds over six quarters - a really
huge win so being a look at that
reliably and have like consistent smooth
improvement predictably and we were
doing this with a team with a database
team of two people one of whom was a new
grad out of college and the other of
whom was like a 21 year old who joined
the company was 18 is 18 so I think
that's like particularly cool that we've
been able to pull this off with a really
small team of people who are like very
smart very hardworking but not like I
don't know the Michael Jordan of
performance or something like that it's
like normal engineers are able to
generate really good wins with it with
this sort of methodology another thing
is very cool about it is that we can
test all kinds of different changes
here's just some examples we can
basically test any different layer of
the stack we've we've gotten wins at the
hardware layer the OS config the file
system config the database config the
database schema the indexing stratagems
have a database the way the queries are
run on top of that like the vacuuming
strategy all kinds of related a queue
basically tests anything that we want to
do the only things that you can't test
with this approach are things that are
basically rewrites of this system like
anything that is an incremental change
you can test but if your if your
proposed change is like rip out
everything and replace it with HBase
like we obviously can't test that but
anything that's like a node level a
worker node level change we can
basically test some tests are harder to
run than others usually because it's
harder to set up the Michigan a certain
way than others but like it's super
flexible even able to get like pretty
impressive wins basically everywhere and
this is just a graph of the basically
the inverse of the performance so we
have an even time we have a max customer
size that we are that we were able to
serve and every time we get a
performance improvement that goes up
we're able to serve a larger customer so
this is that over the last 18 months
it's like a smooth steady improvement
where every month or two the number
takes up and were able to serve a larger
customer that's a happy graph the reason
for the huge uptick in April is that we
deployed three different like
accumulated wins at once that needed a
particularly complex rollout another
thing that's kind of cool about this
just as like a back story
that that's a two-person thing that has
a bunch of other stuff that they need to
do like they build new analysis features
and stability improvements and other
stuff and towards the end of last year
like October through beginning of this
year we actually took our foot off the
gas from a performance point of you
because we'd outstripped the business's
ability to sell it was no longer
constrain anything for our business so
we've been able to pull this off with a
team of two people that has other
responsibilities also and that this
hasn't been their top priority the whole
time so this is happy like this is like
exactly what we're looking for
predictable reliable improvement like
also in this time we've had basically no
degradation there's got nothing that we
shipped that had problems we had a lot
of things that we caught in shadow prod
it's like subtle waves our product could
be degraded by a thing and we wouldn't
have caught but but we haven't had any
like tire fire stuff so generally what
this works really well because it's it's
super easy from a safety point of view
to be confident that something is safe
for prod because it's already in prod
like you're there's there's really not a
whole lot of way that this thing is
running differently than prod when it's
in your shadow prod thing so it's like
easy to be confident you can promote it
you like you're running exactly the same
workload on it if you're really worried
about something you just run it for
longer but you're basically it's already
in prod you're just ignoring the results
from it and then added bonus is that you
can set up you can basically get a free
test of your roll out process which is
often a complex thing too if you have a
petabyte of data but you can hydrate
that shadow prod node the same way you
would have rolled out the change and you
get a free smoke test of that whole
process here are some pro tips if you're
interested in building a system like
this for yourself first pro tip I would
strongly suggest that you use that you
do have a whole bunch of AAA tests to
expose any kind of confounding variables
in your setup Nate says you can think of
this whole thing as an a/b test for your
data layer and AHS is an a/b test where
there's no variation like you set up a
shadow prod no that's an exact clone of
a prod node with no changes and if
there's a difference there and how they
perform there's something that you need
to know about either that means you're
setting it up in a weird way or there's
like an important variable that
determines the performs other thing that
you're gonna learn about they're gonna
figure out from this or it at the very
least if you want to be confident that
your results are good you need to know
that your baseline is not high variance
like the variance between what you see
in a baseline
like no variation shadow prod node and
the product covin of that needs to be
really small compared to the change
introduced by your feature otherwise
it's like you're just measuring noise or
you have to run your tests forever
something like that another pro tip the
the ability to align specific atoms in
in your experiment between your prod and
your shadow prod is super key by the
specific atoms I mean like the
underlying things that you're trying to
optimize we have this set up it may be
easier if it's concrete we have this set
up such that the individual queries that
go to each worker and the shadow prod
equivalent we can line up the actual
queries the specific mechanism for us is
it like we Jam a comment into the sequel
that has like a sequel comment that has
a hash in it and we're getting the raw
sequel in the other enemy can line we
could parse it out and line them up the
specific mechanism is what's important
like what matters is that that we can
line up the prod query and the shadow
product Quillen of that so you're not
comparing distributions of results
you're comparing query to query and this
is super key because it means you can do
valuable subgroup analyses like if you
if you aren't getting a win that you
expected or something like that you can
like dig into why or if you can find the
sub areas of your product that degrade
even if the macro thing is positive like
this is this turns out to be so
foundational so key that I would suggest
designing your whole thing with this in
mind this is like a first order top of
your decision tree trade-off that I
would build around just like because
it's there's so many things that you can
do with this that you otherwise can't do
like another another thing you can do
for example is ensure that you're
getting the same queries in both that
like exactly the queries that you have
in node a or node B are the same and
like for us that's queries for you that
might be something unrelated but the
ability to line up the atoms as opposed
to just the distributions is is
something I would suggest building
around relatedly we have gotten a lot of
mileage out of building a synod checker
to make sure that the improvements that
we're getting makes sense this is
another great way to expose confounding
variables in your experiment for example
we are lining up all of like query for
query every query on the the shadow prod
node and every career on the prod node
and if a thing gets faster that
shouldn't have gotten faster
we want to flag that because either it
means that our change has an effect that
we didn't know about or that there's an
important thing to learn about in like
or we said if the experiment wrong we're
just going to learn about the world from
this for example if we add an index what
I would expect we basically have a set
of allowed transformations from the prod
version to the new version so if I add
an index as my experiment and a
reasonable transformation would be
replacing a sequential scan with a scan
that uses that index replacing a scanner
hits of worse index with that index but
as a transformation that does not make
sense is like just a different set of
scans that doesn't like something is
wrong there or you need to at least
learn something and this is another
really powerful way to flush out weird
confounding variables for example
another another thing that you might
want to check if you're us is queries
with the same query plan should not have
different performance if I have a query
that uses my new index and have a
different plan it should be faster or it
should be at least different if I have
two queries that had the exact same plan
but one of them is a lot faster like
something is like the hardware is diff
something is different here in my
results I should be suspect I think the
general theme here is like be incredibly
suspicious of your results at all times
and treat them with with maximal
scrutiny don't don't take don't take
like a comfortable happy number on face
value because often it's not real like
you'd rather you'd rather find the
variability here then when you roll the
thing onto prod and don't get the
benefits that you think you're gonna get
so I'm gonna like generalize this a
little bit such that sort of like
explain the the thinking behind this and
maybe some more abstract ways that this
can be useful to you beyond just
database stuff forgive the like enormous
reductive nosov this thought experiment
but let's plot all of the ways that
software can have a problem on a single
axis from super foreseeable to super
unforeseeable so a really foreseeable
stuff would be like type errors these
are stuff that you can foresee usually
pretty locally for example like a type
error is usually like one line of code
where you reference a number as a string
or a string as a number or something
like that and super local super
foreseeable or that I'm inspecting would
have
like business logic problems where you
you you forgot to sort this result said
and there's a problem and the thing from
that like it's local it's like local to
a function or something like that and
then at the far other an in spectrum
you'd have performance stuff like it's
it's generally pretty unpredictable how
something will perform like if you ask
any data layer guru how fast HBase will
be on my product they'll say yeah you
just have to you have to like benchmark
your workload on it there's there's no
telling it's just too complex it's it's
a system level thing on a local level
thing or beyond that there's like
environmental variability like if your
thing is on pram and it's gonna be run
in a million different configurations
environments like there's just so much
variance that's introduced by that that
it's gonna be hard for you to know all
the problems up front and then like the
maximally unforeseen thing would be like
entropy itself like like Amazon has some
weird network and machine failures
happening at the same time and you break
in a way didn't expect or like a cosmic
ray flips a bit on your platter and like
your disk is cut like there's an
infinite that goes all the way to
forever in terms of like the universe is
out to make your software break so we
have all these different ways software
can break let's add the various
interventions that we make to make
software not break they there's usually
like ways that these map along the same
axis and I think the things that catch
foreseeable issues tend to be more local
and the things that catch systemic
issues tend to be more systemic so for
example the far foreseeable end of the
spectrum you'd have like type-checking
catches your type bugs or integration
test gets your integration bugs or like
static analysis will catch a whole bunch
different bugs in your code far other
into the spectrum you have like low
testing and benchmarking to assess your
your performance those are system level
evaluations not local level evaluations
obviously you can use those things for
local piece of code like the basic idea
here is much more black box and systemic
as opposed to white box and local and
then like the farthest other end of the
spectrum is would be like chaos
engineering which is just introducing
entropy of the world into your thing to
break it before the world does it to you
so it's like making your software
stronger by like adding a slight entropy
to it as possible so like forgive that
you could quibble with any of the
details of where this is here like I
hope the basic idea is not particularly
controversial so the reason that this
works so well for us is that the
a problem of query perfect heap is super
high variability we're working in a
situation where like the the number of
different ways people use this in other
different shapes of their data set is is
enormous and trying to capture all that
stuff in a benchmark is is is going to
be like more uphill than just trying to
introduce the the chaos of the world to
you just to give you some examples like
I sat down for literally two minutes and
try to think of things I know about how
users use this product that are
potentially a value to performance and
there's like an enormous laundry list of
stuff like people and a person will go
in and we'll use the same events
repeatedly because they're analyzing a
shopping cart flow and they'll use the
same event so there's gonna be cash -
certainly it's like super important
catch that in your benchmark or
different customers have super different
shapes of data where they have users
that do a lot of events or uses that do
few events or different kinds of events
or all that stuff or another really
common workflow so when will design a
brand or will create a brand new event
in that visualizer and immediately
analyze it or you have intra weak
variants and four month variants blah
blah blah there's a million different
specific things about how users use this
product that are more complex than like
take some queries that users run and run
them and see if they're faster or slower
and then in the back the backdrop to all
this is like a billion a billion rights
a day of new data coming in thrashing
all of your caches and determining
what's in memory and maintenance
operations and vacuuming and a weekly
backup that hammers the disk and like
they're trying to even capture all of
these things like trying to even foresee
all these things is really hard I'm
working this company for six years and
there's like there's a ton that I don't
know but trying to build a trying to
build a benchmarking suite that captures
all this is like a really complicated
simulation project and I still claim
that you're bound to fail by not seeing
some key variable of how your system is
being used or there or what it's like in
prod or something like that so to like
express this idea in that graph like the
problem of performance engineering for
us is much farther on the unforeseeable
high variant system level side of the
problem then at a typical company and
that's why this approach works so well
for us like benchmarking is always going
to strain to move farther to the right
in that spectrum but but this shadow
product which is coming at it from the
other side and and like embracing the
chaos and variability of prod and
getting that into our code as soon as
possible is gonna
if working better so if I were to boil
this down into into one simplified
thought that you can take with you and
be better engineering leaders if you're
in a context with a ton of variability
you might be off you might be better off
looking for ways to test that very
against that variability safely and prod
as opposed to trying to encode all that
variability and capture in your
benchmarks or if we're gonna simplify
this even more it's like a super simple
mimetic thing if you have a ton of
variability
you should think should I test this in
prod or is there a safe way to test this
in prod or test this in prod and again I
don't mean like Yolo put it in prod I
mean figure out a way to safely put this
thing in front of customers so you can
expose yourself to problems sooner as
opposed to trying to know what all the
problems are gonna be so here is a
totally unrelated example that has come
up in our product underlying our product
is a JavaScript snippet that runs on
your website and captures everything
your users do it's a super sensitive
piece of code it runs on like hundreds
of millions of page loads a hundred
millions of pages a day it's it's like
basically like a piece of the Internet
at this point and it's really really
sensitive because any bugs in there will
lead to permanent damage to a customer's
data set like bugs downstream of here we
can usually recover the data but if this
thing just isn't working there's gonna
be a whole my customers data so it's
irreparable and that's really
unacceptable given the product that we
sell and if you get this wrong you can
break a customer's data set you're gonna
make it a customer's website which is
even more unacceptable like you can
break forms if you're not careful you
can break the customers rendering or
something like that which is like
something that people have absolutely
zero tolerance for for an analytics tool
so we totally can't have this thing
super sensitive and and similarly it's a
problem with huge variation like huge
heterogeneity and how this thing is used
we've we've built a huge integration
test suite across you know browser OS
combinations and different websites that
ways to built websites and and SVG's and
using this library that library and
loading keep this where that way and all
these different variations we use sauce
labs to spin up a ton of selenium and
like test all different ways we can
think of and you can play this game of
like every time there's a problem you
add a new
and you prevent that thing from ever
happening again and you should do that
that's good software engine packs that
we do that too but you get to a certain
point of maturity of the business or
taught or lower and low enough tolerance
for problems here and at some point you
need to be catching these problems
before they happen a first time like
this is a key enough part of our product
that we need to be able to ship changes
to it in a way that isn't like
terrifying every single time so we need
a better way to test this thing like the
variability is just and like trying to
catalogue all of the abuses of CSS and
JavaScript that people have used to make
websites before is like a thing you
could do a PhD thesis on so like trying
to encode all of that like there's
there's no way you're gonna capture
everything at some point you need to
just come at this problem from the other
end of the spectrum and and like expose
yourself sooner to do the problem so
we're building we're taking a similar
approach for building out what you could
call shadow heap jeaious it's the same
principle we're trying to capture all
the variability of the ways that this
piece of software is used by getting it
into the ways that it seems by getting
it in front of all the variability in a
way that is safe and won't break web
sites and what break data sets so the
basic approach here is cooking up a
little thing where you can load two
different versions of the heap J's
snippet on on select customers sites or
a small portion of user base or
something like that and we can
correspond the events that come through
from each of them and see if you know
the new variant is missing some events
or if we think that this new variant
supposed to capture an edge case that is
actually coming through or we can we can
encase this whole thing and a whole
bunch of like error caching and try
caching and safety stuff sandboxing
basically so that so that we are
particularly careful to not break
customers sites with it and we can we
can look for increased error rates any
sort of thing like that it's it's the
same idea see if there's a way we can a
be testing in front of users we've a way
to line up the atoms and compare the
results and then we just discard the
data from the shadow the shadow heap
testing at the end of it once we've made
the evaluation we want to make one last
quick thing I always feel like it's
weird at these kinds of things where a
person talks at you about some work that
their company has done and like it gives
you the impression that they did the
I write any of the code for this thing I
did not build this software I'm just the
person telling you about it these were
the engineers who actually built this
thing that's Jeff Anderson can't Ross
Michael malla Stanley you know Chum get
immunised Rapala vicious and a nerd I
these are people who at some point or
another have either worked extensively
on building the system or used it to get
big performance improvements and deliver
a ton of value and an exceptional bunch
of humans who write really good software
if I do say so myself if you are
interested in working with people who if
you're interested in having your picture
on this slide or like working with them
and bah-bah-bah come talk to me so I
think I have time for like two questions
if one of those workers nodes so you
have like writes data to a Dan stream
system how do you kind of isolate that
so it doesn't right into like other
production stores that's a really good
question
basically we happen to have the
abstractions in place such that that
it's easy to make that never happen but
you have to think through all of those
things like we have to make it such that
the shadows stuff is never read from as
an authoritative thing ever and there's
like a couple of annoying special cases
of that but basically like there's a lot
of really cool tricks if you want to
come to the office I was going to know
there's like a lot of really cool tricks
on how we've implemented this such that
it's safe and gets us the visibility we
want but basically all that is specific
to us or at least specific to siteís
which is the data system that we use to
scale up Postgres but like you'll have
to figure out your own thing hey it was
very interesting talk I have two
questions one is just about the position
on performance engineering it seems like
you know at this point we just used two
horizontal scaling as a solution to
performance and people don't spend as
much time looking at a single node
performance or finite cluster size
performance but you're investing a lot
in that as opposed to let's say taking
an approach where you would say let's
just find a way to burst performance on
the lambda whenever the query is running
too slow so what's the what's the kind
of motivation behind the specific choice
and the amount of effort you're putting
into it and a related question is now
that you have committed to
with disgust oh you have a sense of the
ideal performance your system can give
you so you know where to put in your
effort of which module to optimize first
ahead of the others or when to stop
investing effort into optimizing module
that's interesting
so I'll into the second one first could
think it's a little more a little less
open-ended the second question if I
understand correctly is basically like
do you have a good sense of what the
fundamental limits of this are or how do
you pick the investments the the thing
that we realized before we started this
was that we had we had no shortage of ID
we had a huge list of ideas for ways we
could make this faster like it's a
complex' enough system with enough
moving pieces that like if you work on
the thing you'll think of a million
different like unexplored variables or
ideas or something like that so the
point of this was just to build a system
where we could try as many things as
possible and like the problem we had
before was that testing one of those
things took like months and also still
didn't work well as a testing so I guess
I usually think of it as like kind of
there's a weird metaphor but like kind
of like this Saudi proven oil reserves
thing like there's always like six
months of proven reserves of performance
stuff that we can pull out of this thing
and then how much we want to invest in
that is a question of the business
priorities and stuff we can like to net
up or down run try more things run more
experiments or not the first question
was around like horizontal and vertical
scaling like I'm not sure if I'm not
sure if I don't I certainly don't feel
like we've like taken a weird stance or
something like we're definitely
horizontally scaling this thing - we
can't use a lot of particular text like
we can't allow them to scale this
because getting the data like that the
thing that we're optimizing here is the
local nodes because that's where all the
time goes in the thing so having more of
those wouldn't necessarily help us per
se and in fact we've had some
interesting experiments where things
we're about chopping the data up into
smaller pieces in ways they would might
think would help actually
counterproductive one thing I didn't
tell Joe in any of you sites like all
the things that we learned didn't work
because there's like that's like equally
valuable that a whole lot of stuff that
we found that wasn't didn't work
but I get like I feel like we're doing
all of the above like we do need to
scale this thing horizontally and also
we need to make each node faster because
like we can't throw an infinite amount
of money at this and also I don't
there's like multi-tenancy questions
that like kind of difference to trim the
economics I'll talk about after it
figures out details I have a quick
question do you think that there is an
extreme version of this where this is
the main way people test a lot of
different types of software in the
future maybe in a continuous delivery
pipeline or for things that aren't so
much infrastructure related that's an
interesting question
maybe that's this is the first way you
test your product for example yeah like
that was the dream with a benchmark
we're gonna have a benchmark it was so
good we could put in the CI pipeline and
give us a performance score and even
giving a single number of performance
scores like a crate is like it's like
there's like a 50 dimensional
performance problem there's it's like
even that is something that we've like
kind of failed to be able to do well
doing this and see I I don't know I feel
like doing the idea as like staging is
kind of what we're doing here it's like
a step beyond see I like shadow heap j/s
is too is like kind of staging for the
Hejaz snippet or shadow prod is kind of
staging for the database so I see it is
more of an analog to like a be testing
that your product manager might do
[Music]